I don't really think Republicans have
capitalized well or forced a unwilling
press to talk about a lot of the moods
that the Biden Administration has made
in terms of cultural issues so they
haven't talked a whole lot about
how the Biden Administration is now
redefining sex in Title IX an
organization that I work for Independent
Women's Forum an independent women's
voice we've been talking a lot about
Title IX and those issues but I don't
think I don't see as enough Republicans
elected Republicans really going after
Democrats on the things that Joe Biden
has done with regard to the definition
of sex with regard to women's sports
they redefine sex to mean whatever you
feel like that day